Everyone loves a good ghost story.
Whether you’re crowded around a campfire
or watching a YouTube video at 3 AM, there’s
something fun and exciting about imagining
haunted places plagued by strange noises and
apparitions.
Part of what makes it so fun is the idea that
any place can be haunted, especially if terrible
things have happened there.
That decrepit old house at the end of your
street, that 80 year old movie theater where
no one goes anymore, a park where one too
many kids went missing.
All it takes is a tragic backstory and a creepy
atmosphere, and it’s easy to believe that
any place could be teeming with restless spirits.
So, it stands to reason that a place with
as many unsolved deaths as the SCP Foundation
might have a ghost or two lurking in the shadows.
If you’ve ever suspected that the SCP foundation
might be haunted, well…you’d be right.
It began, as all good ghost stories do, with
a series of frightening, unexplained events.
Some time ago, personnel at SCP Foundation
Site-30 began to notice strange things happening
around the facility.
Obviously, at a place like an SCP Foundation
Containment Site, strange is relative, but
these events seemed to have nothing to do
with any of the entities contained at the
site.
There were unexplained sounds reported in
the private quarters of agents and researchers,
ranging from whispers to screams from an unseen
being.
Personnel who approached the D-Class block
at the site noticed an immediate drop in temperature,
with some employees even claiming that they
could see their own breath.
Several personnel reported items going missing
while they were alone in a room.
Most were small and easily misplaced objects
like pens and clipboards, but one man said
his wallet disappeared, which wouldn’t be
that strange if it hadn’t been securely
inside his lab coat.
Other personnel would be innocently washing
their hands, only to be horrified by the appearance
of a bloody figure in a D-Class jumpsuit in
the mirror, staring back at them with hatred
in its eyes.
There were anomalous computer server errors,
the feeling of being watched or followed by
some menacing invisible force, even the sight
of a shadowy silhouette fleeing down corridors
and hiding around corners.
All of these occurrences were reported to
higher-ups at the Foundation, but they were
all dismissed.
The Directorial Board of the site insisted
that these accounts were likely the result
of employees cracking under the mental stress
of working under such strenuous circumstances.
If left alone, they were certain that the
reports would stop.
But the reports didn’t stop, and they soon
found out that this was only the beginning.
There was an uptick in containment breaches
following these initial reports.
In total, twelve different entities were released
from their containment, and the origin of
these breaches could not be identified.
Thankfully, the entities were captured and
returned to their containment facilities before
any casualties could result.
But from there things kept getting worse.
Over the course of several months, there were
six different employee suicides on site.
Security footage of the deceased operatives
shortly before their deaths showed them acting
deeply troubled, engaging in agitated conversation
with someone not visible to the camera.
At first, it was posited that whoever was
upsetting the employees was in a blind spot,
but it quickly became clear that the dead
employees were being tormented by something
invisible.
Stories of hauntings were one thing, but now
with escaped SCPs and a notable death count,
the Directorial Board decided to mount an
official investigation into the unexplained
occurrences.
It was then that the spirit was officially
acknowledged, identified, and re-classified
as SCP-4973.
SCP-4973 was once a D-Class worker who was
used as a guinea pig in 25 different experiments
with a variety of entities on site.
He was repeatedly exposed to multiple unusual
and dangerous anomalies, including SCP-158,
a large mechanical arm capable of extracting
an unidentified substance from any living
test subject.
Before he was brought on board at SCP Foundation
Site-30, he was known as Gordon Kardivachlus
Markovitch, a man who had been convicted of
Murder in the Second Degree after stabbing
his wife 24 times in the chest with a kitchen
knife.
During his incarceration, Markovitch was transferred
to the custody of the SCP Foundation and placed
at Site-30 where he was given a new name,
D-10000.
During an experiment involving a redacted
entity, D-10000 was killed and his remains
were disposed of at a nearby waste refinery.
It was then only three months after his death,
that the initial reports of ghost activity
began.
SCP-4973 is regarded as a Class IV Spectral
Entity, meaning that it is an entity displaying
a high degree of aggression and malevolence
toward a specific individual or group.
In this case, the spirit displays hostility
towards a very specific group - the SCP Foundation.
Class IV entities can affect the environment
around them, move objects, reduce the temperature
in a room, and induce hallucinations in humans
that it comes into contact with.
These hallucinations are thought to be the
cause of the increase in employee suicides
that occurred after 4973’s first appearance.
One of the many ways in which SCP-4973 acted
out, in what is believed to be an attempt
at revenge on the Foundation as a whole, was
to somehow gain access to the SCiPNET Database
Terminal.
This allowed the spirit to learn about the
entities contained at the site, as well as
personal details regarding the lives of research,
security, and administrative staff working
there.
This information is likely what allowed 4973
to cause several suspected containment breaches,
though the specifics of those breaches have
been expunged from official records.
4973 was eventually contained within an apparatus
known as an Incorporeal Entity Vacuum Chamber,
which is consistently monitored by a team
of specialists within MTF Mu-13, affectionately
nicknamed “Ghostbusters.”
In order to prevent it from escaping, four
Harrington-Hollow Neutralizer Wards have been
placed at the door to the containment facility.
This containment method has been largely effective,
though the spirit has escaped a handful of
times and had to be recaptured and placed
back into the IEVC.
In order to understand SCP-4973, and uncover
how it was able to access the database, Dr.
Lorraine Casper was assigned to conduct an
interview with the spirit, speaking to it
as it was in containment, and a transcript
of this interview is available in the official
Foundation archives.
Dr. Casper began the conversation politely,
addressing the SCP as Gordon and asking him
how he was.
Gordon refused to comply with the round of
questioning, going as far as to yell at Dr.
Casper until she reminded him that he faced
the risk of termination if he refused to answer
her questions.
Dr. Casper pointed out that the files accessed
by 4973 required clearance that the spirit
would have no way of possessing.
He responded that he simply waved his hand
across the terminal in order to access it,
explaining: “It freaked out for a second
and then it just - stopped...
I could just move my fingers around the air
and the tabs would just roll up.
Easy as that.”
Dr. Casper asked for clarification, inquiring
how he could even do something like that.
4973 continued his explanation, “Beats me.
It felt like some attraction.
Like magnets from afar getting closer and
closer.
I dunno, something like that.”
Finding this answer unsatisfactory, Dr. Casper
pushed further, asking for an explanation
of SCP-4973’s attempts to release dangerous
onsite anomalies from containment.
This question seemed to stump him, and he
claimed not to understand what Dr. Casper
meant.
She explained that the ID cards of Dr. Yurkov
and Dr. Orson were used to open the facilities
from which these anomalies escaped.
4973 was shocked that he had been suspected
of this attack, and insisted not to know who
Orson or Yurkov even were.
All of a sudden, he trailed off.
There was silence for a moment, and Dr. Casper
began to collect her notes and leave, assuming
that the interview was over.
Much to her surprise, SCP-4973 began to laugh,
a loud uproarious laugh of complete and utter
delight.
Casper asked what 4973 was laughing about,
and was met with the response: “God, this
whole time, you and your ghost-hunting crew
never knew?”
He refused to clarify what it was exactly
the doctor and her crew had missed, only saying
“God, that look on your face when you find
out it’s been right under your noses this
whole time.”
He continued to laugh at Dr. Casper for the
remainder of the interview, refusing to answer
any further questions or explain any of his
comments.
Finally, Dr. Casper grew exasperated and left,
ending the interview for real this time.
Following this perplexing interview, Dr. Casper
inexplicably abandoned her post at Site-30.
Her supervisors could not reach her, neither
could any of the other researchers at the
site.
No one heard from her for an entire week,
until one day she called Director Eric Riverson
of Site-30 on his personal phone line.
He recorded the conversation, and a transcript
has been included in the file for SCP-4973.
Dr. Casper explained to Director Riverson
that she had been hiding in her private residence
away from the site, and that she no longer
considered any part of the site safe.
In fact, she suggested that all SCP Foundation
sites might be potentially compromised.
She explained her conversation with SCP-4973,
and the questions it provoked her to ask.
If he had not been behind the containment
breaches, then who was?
He never encountered Dr. Yurkov or Orson in
any of the tests administered on him, and
Orson wasn’t even employed at the Foundation
until after 4973’s death.
Dr. Casper posited that, though the spirit
of Gordon was not responsible for the breaches,
another spectral force, or forces, at the
site might be.
Her hypothesis?
That Site-30 was positively infested with
the vengeful spirits of Class D employees
lost over the years during various experiments.
In order to prove her theory, Dr. Casper got
her hands on all of the experimental equipment
used by the department researching spectral
anomalies.
The general consensus among researchers in
this field is that spirits leak out a kind
of energy, known as ectoplasm, wherever they
go.
It has been compared to the skin left behind
when a spider or a snake molts, a nonessential
portion of the entity that is shed and leaves
a residue in areas where they have been.
Unsurprisingly, a huge amount of ectoplasm
was detected inside of Site-30.
The spirits went undetected at first, as many
of them were dormant for quite some time.
Dormant spirits are spirits that are not aware
of their surroundings or the circumstances
of their deaths, and they do not emit large
quantities of ectoplasm.
It is likely that, after Gordon was trapped,
several of the dormant spirits of Site-30
began to remember what was done to them, and
manifest in more aggressive ways.
Because Gordon was presumed to be the only
spirit at the site, their gradual appearance
and acting out was either ignored, or presumed
to be Gordon escaping from containment.
After her realization, Dr. Casper identified
an additional five active spirits at the site,
and was able to capture and contain one of
them.
Dr. Casper warned Director Riverson that there
were likely far more spirits than just those
five, and it was only a matter of time before
they woke up and became active like the others.
The large amount of previous containment breaches
attributed to simple “human error” becomes
deeply sinister once it is clear that there
have been vengeful spirits hiding in plain
sight the entire time.
As Gordon put it in his interview, they were
just under their noses the whole time.
Dr. Casper’s findings, and the story of
Site-30, present a troubling possibility.
Every SCP Foundation site has used massive
amounts of Class D Personnel in human experiments
with dangerous entities, and the body count
at nearly all of them is staggering.
If Dr. Casper is right, then every single
site has the makings of a haunted house.
All of them could be infested with the spirits
of dead angry D-Class, who are just waiting
to wake up and take their revenge on the still
living members of the organization that killed
them.
And it’s only a matter of time before they
get the chance.
Now check out “SCP-3999 - I Am At The Center
of Everything That Happens To Me” and “SCP-1007
- Mr. Life and Mr. Death” for more mind
blowing SCP stories!